des carnavaliers par milliers dans les
rues de fort de france parmi eux des
seniors et des familles avec parfois des
enfants très jeunes alors même si
certains d'entre eux semblent fin prêts
à parer toute attaque
la sécurité reste une attente est
essentielle pour ce carnaval vous sentez
en sécurité j'ai mince en sécurité parce
que bon il ya toujours des policiers ya
deux jours déjà de la sécurité alors
pour moi ça va une toujours en famille
le carnaval c'est c'est une fête pour
tout le monde
c'est une fête pour la famille sy et
pour lever toute inquiétude
certains ont leurs petites habitudes
dans toutes les faces au mont pour moi
personnellement j'ai toujours été en
sécurité passagers sait où aller et au
népal les deux on voit que vous inviter
à ça c'est sur moi j'aime pas trop la
savane je parle du monde face à la
savane
pourquoi je sais pas je ne me sens pas
en sécurité sur la savane chez masse en
pourquoi vous préférez le lundi parce
que c'est beaucoup plus calme en ya
moins de monde donc c'est vrai que là je
sens ma fille mise en sécurité
il ya des gens que vous évitez quand
vous êtes avec les enfants oui le
dimanche et le mardi gras
quoi qu'il en soit chaque jour 350
personnes policiers agents de sécurité
médiateurs sont impliqués dans la
sécurité du carnaval plusieurs fois de
palpations sont installés et les
véhicules qui rentre dans la ville sont
également fouillé cette année fort de
france a renforcé la présence des grands
frères passant de moins d'une centaine à
près de 150
un dispositif que le nouveau préfet de
martinique stanislas gazelles est venu
constater vous les connaissez par
ailleurs travaillé le quartier
l'invitation est un bilan qui est fait
chaque année et qui nous permet
effectivement de réajuster c'est le cas
cette année en particulier sur tout ce
qui est axe qui mène au niveau du
centre-ville la fin travail avec les
médiateurs notamment dans les quartiers
pour pacifier des situations on a
beaucoup plus de médiateur cette année
150 notamment avec l'association les
grands frères qui travaillent avec nous
et puis se mettre aussi soit des points
de barriérage ils sont connus pour être
des points importants avec une affluence
importante
chaque jour entre 60000 et 80000
carnavaliers investissent les rues de
fort de france